bien
chers collègues nous entendons ce matin
Monsieur Nicolas midjaville qui est
directeur de la Caisse nationale des
industries électriques et gazières et
nous l'ont tournons sur le projet loi de
financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 autrement dit projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat l'objectif de l'audition est de
présenter les impacts du projet de loi
sur la caisse des électriciens et
gaziers et monsieur mediabid je vais
vous laisser la parole pour un propos
introductif avant que nous rapporteurs
et les abdouano rapporteur général René
Paul Savary rapporteur pour les
retraites et Sylvie vermeiller que je
salue rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances et puis les
commissaires ne vous adressent leurs
questions je vous laisse tout de suite
la parole monsieur
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci tout d'abord de votre accueil dans
une salle bien chauffée grâce aux
industries électriques et gazières
[Rires]
donc je
vous remercie je vous remercie de votre
accueil et de votre présence nombreux
qui manifeste une nouvelle fois j'ai
souvent été accueilli par le sénateur
Savary la qualité et le sérieux de votre
travaux
je voulais simplement vous faire dans
mon propos liminaire rappelé pour ceux
qui le savent moins que de sénateur ça
varie ce qu'est notre régime en quelques
mots et puis ensuite faire une ou deux
réflexion sur les enjeux du projet de
réforme pour ce qui concerne la réforme
des régimes de certains régimes statut
alors sur notre sur notre régime des
industries électriques et gazières ce
que j'observerai d'abord c'est que le
régime est un moyen régime dans les
régimes disspeaux ou statutaire il était
il vient très loin derrière comme vous
le savez la gym de la fonction publique
euh de de d'état civil et militaire très
bien loin derrière la fonction publique
territoriale et la fonction publique
hospitalière et il vient à peu près à
une position assez voisine un peu
derrière en apportant le régime de la
SNCF avec en gros chiffre de l'ordre de
200000 pensionnés de l'ordre de 150 000
associés donc ça c'est les grandes
lignes de notre régime ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que nous avons aussi des
grands chiffres financiers 200 milliards
d'euros d'engagement dans ce régime et
puis surtout ce qu'il faut savoir et
bien connaître et bien avoir l'esprit
c'est important pour la réforme sur
lequel vous la représentation nationale
aura le projet de réforme sur lequel la
représentation nationale aura à
se positionner un statué c'est que nous
avons un adossement qui est très
particulier qui est la doucement
financier qui était mise en place au
début des années 2000 de par la volonté
l'État et avec le plein d' accord et le
plan de travail de l'ensemble de la
branche énergie branche les industries
électriques et gazières cette adossement
je crois que l'État à l'époque avait
l'intention de l'étendre aux autres
régimes spéciaux et puis comme il
n'était pas dans la même situation
financière que le secteur des industries
électriques et gazières cette extension
n'a pas été faite il est extrêmement
précieux vous savez que ça a permis de
déconsolider l'essentiel de la charge
retraite des des comptes des entreprises
notamment à l'époque Gaz de France et
EDF et puis des autres employeurs du du
secteur et ça permet notamment à
l'époque leur
mise sur le marché et leur introduction
en Bourse donc cette
ce
cette adossement vous le connaissez vous
sénateurs puisque chaque année vous avez
à jauger ou à juger sur pas chaque année
je crois le pari a pas régulier je sais
plus quel est le nom de l'année je crois
[Musique]
ses droits passés passés aujourd'hui
sont servis par la contribution au tarif
d'acheminement et cette contribution est
neutre pour le consommateur c'est aussi
important avoir l'esprit c'est-à-dire
qu'à l'époque ça a été simplement un
transfert du tarif vers une PACS c'était
pris dans le tarif et il y a pas eu
augmentation du tarif et encore
aujourd'hui on est dans ce même système
donc deux éléments de neutralité qui
sont importants à avoir l'esprit sur
l'adossement
au-delà de la doucement je crois que ce
qui est important à avoir l'esprit c'est
que
ce régime est aussi un régime équilibré
c'est un régime qui a toujours été
équilibré il est de par la loi et il le
sera si la réforme devait passer il
continuera à l'être et on aura
l'occasion de l'expliquer dans les
questions que vous nous avez posées nous
avons des éléments de réponse qui vous
seront fournies par écrit de façon
détaillée sur ce point c'est un régime
enfin qui est pleinement autonome quant
à sa gestion c'est important à souligner
que dans les régimes de retraite et vous
le savez pour tous ceux qui sont
spécialistes de la retraite le nerf de
la guerre c'est beaucoup l'informatique
et nous avons une informatique
pleinement autonome ce qui pour un moyen
régime et est une performance dont je
suis fier enfin je suis fier pour mes
équipes et avec une qualité de gestion
qui était très très reconnue dans la
sécurité sociale on est un des régimes
qui a vraiment la meilleure qualité de
gestion on le voit qualité-gestion et
qualité aussi dans les enquêtes de
clientèle de satisfaction de nos clients
de sa situation de nos pensionnés de nos
affiliés qui sont à un très très haut
niveau
qualité également dans tous les audits
que l'on peut faire sur les métiers sur
la finance on a des auditeurs comptables
je crois qu'on est la seule caisse de
sécurité sociale qui n'est jamais eu la
moindre réserve de la part de ces
auditeurs comptables et nous avons de la
part des corps de l'État qui exercent
leur fonction de contrôle que ce soit la
Cour des comptes que ce soit Liga ce que
ce soit le contrôleur le contrôle
général finance nous avons eu toujours
plutôt des appréciations très élogieuses
sur la conduite de notre régime je
tenais après je tenais le préciser c'est
à ça peut paraître un peu loin du propos
mais je crois que c'est important avoir
à l'esprit sur le pour la suite côté
employeur je crois que ce qui est
important à voir l'esprit là c'est le
nombre d'employeurs on a toujours l'idée
c'est EDF et engie en simplifiant en
réalité vous vous le savez puisque vous
êtes élus des territoires vous
représentez bien les vous représentez
bien l'ensemble de la France
nous il y a 160 employeurs aujourd'hui
plus qu'il n'y en avait il y a 20 ans
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on avait 130
quand on a créé la CNEG il y a bien sûr
tout ce qu'on appel fois l'économie mix
les entreprises locales de distribution
dans les territoires et puis aussi tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui créent une activité
dans les énergies nouvelles
renouvelables et qui ont une activité
réseau une activité de fourniture qui
justifie que ce soit des entreprises qui
entrent au statut des industries
électriques et gazières de par la loi
alors je vais finir mon propos par des
réflexions un peu plus sur les enjeux un
premier enjeu sur lequel je me permets
d'attirer votre attention c'est
l'attractivité ou non du secteur vous
savez qu'il y a eu des
à l'Assemblée nationale il y a une
commission d'enquête sur le secteur du
service public de la fourniture
d'électricité et du gaz
au regard de l'indépendance nationale et
la souveraineté et un des points qui a
pu me frapper qui a frappé tous ceux qui
ont eu la curiosité d'écouter les
auditions c'est que le secteur est moins
attractif moi quand je suis entré dans
secteur il y a une vingtaine d'années
c'était un secteur qui accueillait les
talents facilement que ce soit les
meilleures écoles d'ingénieurs ou les
meilleures écoles de toutes sortes ont
montré où à tous niveaux jusqu'à l'agent
de l'exécution on avait vraiment intérêt
des talents aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus difficile et pourquoi je peux place
ceci j'attire votre attention sur ce
point parce que
le français quand a appris à considérer
les régimes de retraite comme étant la
couverture sociale d'un secteur ce n'est
pas du tout la réalité c'est un prisme
déformant le régime de retraite n'est
qu'un des éléments quand on parle
d'équité ou pas d'équité les régimes
retraite il faudrait avoir une vision
beaucoup plus générale ça a l'air et
couverture sociale et la couverture de
sociale de notre secteur elle est ce
qu'elle est elle est très probablement
beaucoup moins bonne que la convention
collective des banques dont j'ai été
banquier dans le passé je me souviens de
cette convention elle est très
probablement moins bonne que ce que l'on
achète total donc il faut avoir cela il
me semble à l'esprit quand on quand on
parle de la réforme de ce de ce régime
et
dernier point
à ce sujet sur lequel je voudrais
attirer votre attention c'est que les
mesures de convergence de toutes les
réformes depuis la réforme Balladur de
93 et surtout des dernières réformes de
2010 de
2014 de 2017
de 2006 on a de toutes les dernières
réformes ont vraiment amené des mesures
de convergence qui font que en réalité
pour le nouvel entrant il conserve un
avantage fidélisant avec ce régime de
retraite mais cet avantage fidélisant
est assez limité assez limité et
d'ailleurs on le voit par un aspect qui
est intéressant qui est les départs sans
anticipation les EHPAD départ sensitives
anticipation aujourd'hui ils sont
exactement même âge que dans le régime
général 62,9 partons exactement comme
pour les salariés qui partent sans
anticipation exactement au même âge pour
les salariés qui partent en anticipant
et plus les salariés qui partent sans
anticipation la moyenne est aujourd'hui
de 60,4 je crois donc on est évidemment
de retard sur un impôts sous du régime
général mais ce cette ce décalage est
aussi lié au décalage qu'il y a eu dans
les différents dispositifs de loi où il
y avait un temps d'application qui était
plus long pour la montée
en
charge des réformes dans le régime des
industries électriques et donc j'ai
évoqué l'actrice l'attractivité je
voudrais évoquer deux points qui sont
plus peut-être d'intendants mais je sais
qu'une très grande personnalisée disait
l'intendance suivra la tendance dans nos
métiers c'est très très important et
cette c'est le succès où l'échec d'une
réforme il y a un premier élément
d'intendance qui est l'élément
gestion des nouveaux entrants avec l'âge
du grand-père et gestion des eaux de
populations alors il y a un élément très
simple qui est mal algérial qui est de
ressources humaines comment j'explique à
quelqu'un qui travaille dans dans les
pylônes électriques finalement il y a
ils sont réglés ils ont tous la même le
même statut mais qu'il y en a qui ont un
statut un peu plus doré que les autres
je pense que managérialement ça n'est
pas simple en terme de gestion des
ressources humaines ce n'est pas simple
au point de vue juridique traitement
administratif traitement
informatique ça n'est pas simplement
informatique je voudrais vraiment
insister sur ce point quand on nous dit
c'est en septembre 2023 que le régime
que la loi devrait être en oeuvre pour
les pour les régimes statutaires ou
spéciaux
2023 n'y pensez pas au point de vue
informatique c'est ce que vous diront
les informaticiens vous dire quel que
soit l'argent que vous voulez mettre
dans le système nous ne serons pas prêts
donc là mon alerte si si j'ai à y mettre
une alerte devant vous c'est et c'est
pas du tout dans l'idée de dire il faut
freiner la retraite la réforme c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas ma
responsabilité de savoir ce qu'il faut
faire comme réforme dans le pays sauf
quand je vote mais c'est mais ça
s'arrête là et bien de ce point de vue
là moi je me permets d'alerter votre
commission sur le fait que si nous
allons trop vite on aura on peut avoir
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon des informaticiens une
catastrophes industrielles ça peut ne
pas fonctionner tout simplement et puis
ça peut aussi coûter beaucoup plus cher
donc c'est un c'est un point et enfin
[Musique]
j'ai évoqué la tranquillité j'ai évoqué
la gestion et je l'évoquais
l'informatique je crois que sont les
grands sujet et puis enfin je l'ai
évoqué en introduction Le la dosement
financier la dosement financier pour
l'instant le projet de réforme ne dit
rien sur ce que seront les conditions
financières dans le futur pour nous dans
les industries électriques et gazières
nous avons un système qui est très
solide ceci system restera solide si la
réforme est adoptée il restera solide
jusqu'à l'extinction du régime et donc
on a vraiment on a étudié le sujet et
donc notre prière si nous avions une
prière à faire ça serait préservé ce
système d'adossement et je crois de
toutes les façons
il faut résoudre les problèmes
financiers aujourd'hui sont déjà très
résolus grâce à vraiment ce travail
intelligent qui a fait l'état à l'époque
avec la notion financière du secteur des
industries électriques merci beaucoup de
votre attention et je suis évidemment
disponible pour vos questions
vous rapporteront m'ont fait parvenir
une liste de 13 questions auxquelles
nous répondons par écrit de manière très
détaillée mais évidemment on peut
revenir sur ces questions si vous le
souhaitez et puis surtout
oui merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues merci Monsieur le Directeur de
nous avoir donné les éléments de
réflexion pour ce changement pour pour
votre comment régime
je voudrais revenir tout simplement sur
l'aspect financier des choses parce que
c'est en tout cas le rôle d'un
rapporteur général mais c'est aussi
important que tout le monde sache
qu'elles sont les répercussions de ce
changement sur le plan financier et donc
ma première question parce que
l'ensemble de mes collègues n'ont pas eu
le questionnaire donc on va en fait vous
poser les questions que nous avons
envoyé il y a quelques jours donc la
première question c'est sur la situation
financière de la branche vieillesse du
régime général au 31 décembre 2022
est-ce que vous pouvez me donner
quelques chiffres par rapport justement
à votre
à votre comment régime et puis quel
incidence le report à 64 ans de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à compter de la
génération 1968 et l'accélération de la
longement de la durée d'assurance
requise pour l'obtention du taux plein
donc c'est porté à 43 à nuités à compter
de la génération 1965 au lieu de 1973
auront-ils sur la trajectoire financière
du régime et puis je voudrais rappeler à
mes collègues que en fait quand on se
penche sur par exemple une feuille de
paix d'un employé chez vous on remarque
que le taux est plus élevé que comment
dans le régime de base générale il est à
38,68 et c'est pas le cas pour les
autres mais en réalité ce qu'il faut
savoir aussi c'est que l'assiette elle
est plus large et ce qui permet d'avoir
la même somme en
définitive mais à quoi est dû c'est ce
choix de finalement de cotisations plus
élevées à ce qu'il y a quelque part une
histoire à ce choix ou pas enfin je me
suis posé la question et puis la
troisième question
la troisième question oui je crois je me
suis trompé de feuilles en fait oui oui
parce qu'en fait j'aurais dû vous poser
la question quelle est la situation
financière du régime des industries
électriques et gazières au 31 décembre
ensuite quels sont les spécificités du
régime par rapport aux autres régimes
obligatoires de base et quel incidence
le report ça je viens de la poser donc
vous pourrez en prendre voilà bonne note
et puis me donner une réponse merci
alors merci merci merci merci madame le
sénateur
je vais je vais prendre le bon ordre des
questions et répondre aux dernières si
vous le voulez bien donc sur la
situation financière c'est assez simple
notre régime à la particularité je l'ai
dit toute chose tout à l'heure d'étrange
en équilibre de par la loi et des facto
nous avons toujours été en équilibre
depuis la création de la série IEG et
depuis la création donc de la caisse et
de la branche énergie en 2000 et c'est
même si même si la réalité pardon
excusez-moi vous m'entendiez mal je suis
désolé
je vais recommencer mon propos tout à
l'heure
je suis vraiment désolé d'avoir merci
monsieur le sénateur donc
régime équilibré de par la loi et régime
équilibré de faits et régime équilibré
en perspective pour les comptes 2022
même s'il y a les comptes 2022 ne sont
pas encore arrêtés nous sommes certains
qui seront que les régimes sera
équilibré un point notez l'excédent de
trésorerie c'est important avoir
l'esprit je pense que le sénateur
s'avary il a parfaitement à l'esprit
nous avons une contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement dans notre régime je sais
que à d'autres occasions il a pu
m'interroger sur ce point cette
contribution tarifaire d'achevinement
elle produit des excédents de trésorerie
qui sont toujours aujourd'hui de 700
millions sur les sur les comptes de 2022
c'est 700 millions en fait sont gérés
par la cosse pour le germe pour le
régime général donc il faut
je crois avoir clairement
ne pas avoir l'idée que nous sommes en
train de faire des réserves cachées
que j'ai pu lire parfois dans des
articles mal informés de la presse donc
voilà pour le pour l'excédent de
trésorerie on garde une petite partie de
l'électricité dans le trésorerie qui est
vraiment justifiée par rapport à ce que
nous connaissons nos comptes
c'est-à-dire que sur les 700 millions
pour parler clair on a à peu près 100
millions que nous gardons nous
pour comme pour faire pour faire face à
nos pointes
à nos pointes à nos bases trésorerie et
c'est largement suffisant et le reste
est totalement géré par la cause pour le
compte du régime général alors sur le la
question je crois du de la durée la
durée qui irait jusqu'à je crois que
c'est l'incidence de la durée qui irait
jusqu'à 64 ans je crois que c'était
votre question et donc sur cet incidence
il est clair que elle va toucher d'abord
des gens qui sont au statut et qui ont
une assiette enfin qui vous le savez ont
sont sur les six derniers mois de
salaire donc pas les 25 ans en fonction
publique ni la totalité de la carrière
comme avec dans la Jago une manière
observation alors c'est pas une
observation scientifique mais c'est une
observation qui a été faite
à l'époque où Yannick Moreau avait
demandé des études sur ce sujet et puis
à différentes époques où le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites a demandé
des études sur ce point en fait quand on
regarde les taux de remplacement de
salaire dans notre dans notre branche
ils sont en fait très voisin de ce qu'on
a dans le régime général et dans la
fonction publique alors ça tient
notamment à l'effet prime qui n'est pas
prise en compte donc il ne faut pas
penser qu'il y a des différences très
significatives je j'ai insisté sur les
mesures de convergence tout à l'heure
c'est vraiment des mesures de
convergence réelle
néanmoins on a quand même cet impact et
il est clair que pour les les finances
du régime on aura quelque chose de plus
coûteux en amenant 64 ans puisque nous
nous sommes des entreprises où il n'y
aura pas de plancher de plantes très
retraite mise en place de manière très
importante on aura probablement on
poursuivra chez que ce soit entre quatre
ans comme on a su d'ailleurs très
poursuivre comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure jusqu'à 69 était était depuis
quelques années
donc donc voilà la réponse à cette
question là sur une autre question je
crois que vous aviez posé sur le
l'équilibre de du régime sur les les les
anémies en dehors de l'obligation légale
en réalité la sortie d'un côté des
nouveaux entrants et le traitement du du
stock de droit acquis
ne nous inquiétez pas si la doucement
est maintenu c'est-à-dire que du point
du financier si l'adossement est
maintenu nous sommes nous sommes à
Seraing sur sur la gestion de ce régime
à
court terme à moyen terme et à long
terme je dirais même jusqu'à très long
terme puisqu'on par rapport à une autre
question que vous aviez posé et vous
avez posé à quel moment s'éteindra le
régime on a calculé que en 2000 pardon
en 2073
on aurait encore 40% je crois de là
40%
de moins dans de prestation mais qu'on
aurait pu de nouveau droit et en 2113
seulement quand je serai très âgé si
j'étais renouvelé mais je vais pas être
renouvelé j'ai déjà 68 ans je m'en vais
en retrait de cette année mais quand
aussi mon prédécesseur bénéficie des des
du génie des lot de musk il pourra
liquider tout seul la dernière portion
en 2113
on n'est pas le Savary pour la suite des
questions ensuite Sylvie je suis le
directeur connaissant bien le sujet ce
qui serait pas plus simple pour nos
collègues de suivre les questions et il
répond rapidement très bien
comme ça c'est clair net toute façon
synthétique les précisions vont nous les
amener par écrit c'est pas c'est pas que
si je prends je prends la question 2 si
vous voulez qui était vous commencez à
la 4 hein
je pose la question si vous souhaitez et
vous amenez la réponse
quel serait l'effet de ces ajustements
des ajustements paramétrés proposés sur
la pension moyenne alors sur la pension
moyenne elle devrait augmenter ne
serait-ce que du fait mais 64 ans c'est
tout à fait logique elle devrait
augmenter par les par l'effet de salaire
de fin de carrière potentiellement plus
élevée pardon à l'issue des deux années
supplémentaires effectuées
l'accès l'opération de la de
l'augmentation telle que de la durée
d'assurance qui était une autre question
pour régénérer deux effets à notre sens
il y a un effet qui est bon je je prends
et je ne vais je vais éviter la décote
et je continue à travailler et puis il y
a un effet qui est de dire finalement je
préfère avoir un peu moins et partir
plus tôt il nous est très difficile
aujourd'hui de jauger cela on accepte
certaines expériences dans le passé ça
dépend un peu des notions des éléments
de pouvoir d'achat dans le pays et puis
des éléments d'intérêt du travail
c'est-à-dire que si dans les yeux j'ai
le pouvoir d'achat qui est quand même
réputé un peu meilleur que dans d'autres
secteur d'activité
contenu des catégories
socioprofessionnelles qu'il y a dans le
secteur
il y a intérêt du travail travail
intéressant et pas que par ailleurs
comme l'ensemble du pays avec des soucis
pouvoir d'achat on pourrait avoir une
durée d'assurance qui qui s'élève mais
ce n'est pas forcément du tout ce qui se
prend de passera c'est des éléments
d'incertitude autre question
[Musique]
alors
lequel part du total des départs en
retraite représenté donc en 2022
actuellement les départs anticipés pour
carrière longue alors par exemple
combien de pour carrière longue ça
représente 5% du total c'est à dire que
nous avons eu à peu près 4000 départs
l'an dernier et vous devez on peut
considérer que les dépend anticipés pour
carrière longue c'est 5 % du total 5 %
et les pour incapacités
5% environ pour carrière longue hein
d'accord et pour incapacité permanente
ou handicap ça représente handicap
05% et ainsi capacité permanente 5%.
d'accord à 5% autant en capacité
permanente
l'incidence sur le nombre de départ
anticipés au cours des projets années
notamment le report à 62 ans
pour ceux qui ont un taux d'incapacité
qui sera compris entre 10 et 19%, et le
fait de de passer de 5 à 17 ans d'année
d'exposition de facteurs de pénibilité
vous allez être touché par cette
disposition différentes oui bien sûr on
sera touché alors sur le sur votre
première que question sur le sur le
report à 62 ans de la gelée par le
régime spécial propose une anticipation
spécifique au titre du taux d'incapacité
permanente par par suite d'accident de
travail ou maladie professionnelle à DMP
et donc l'abaissement avec un
abaissement de l'âge d'ouverture de
droit de trois mois ou de 6 mois donc
voilà pour cet incidence et que pour le
repas de l'âge à 64 ans qui était je
crois votre autre question on aura
mécaniquement un recul de l'âge de
départ pour ces salariés
on aura évidemment du fait de
et on aura quand on prend en compte les
trimestres réputés cotisés le bénéfice
de la retraite anticipée pour carrière
longue d'eau plus alors je vais pas
entrer peut-être dans la question c'est
par rapport à la capacité c'est
n'importe quoi parce que si vous voulez
le fait de décaler ça va apporter
effectivement
ceux qui sont en incapacité selon
l'exposition des facteurs de pénibilité
ça pourrait les décaler
vous permettez peut-être à Monsieur
Duchêne qui est notre directeur contrat
ça représente beaucoup mais
effectivement par rapport à la mécanique
que vous a indiqué Nicolas midjaville va
y avoir un décalage dans le temps
puisqu'on se cale sur l'âge d'ouverture
de droit pour fixer les les trois mois
et 6 mois dont on a dans ton appareil
tout de suite donc effectivement il va
avoir un décalage dans le temps c'est ça
la question que vous posez c'est d'avoir
un décalage où il y aura un décalage les
gens partiront plus tard en
mais le fait d'avoir des facteurs de
pénibilité de se ramener de à 5 ans au
lieu de 17 ans ça va influer vous savez
pas encore quoi vous n'avez pas pu
mesurer
donc
ce qui va se passer c'est que pour les
nouveaux entrants qui vont dans le cas
du projet de loi ils vont être au régime
général ils auront les
les sondages et pour ce qui concerne les
statutaires ils ont leur propre système
et c'est ce que Nicolas mijavide vous
explique c'est que pour ces personnages
sont également concernés par la réforme
puisqu'il y aura un décalage dans le
temps puisqu'on se cale sur l'âge
d'ouverture donc il y aura vraiment deux
distinctions de deux catégories de
catégories très différentes de même sur
la VPF ou lava ça va pas forcément
toucher directement les anciens ça va
toucher que les nouveaux dans lequel
effectivement une autre des questions
que vous avez posé la VPF et la fin
s'applique aux salariés des IEG
simplement ça se présente par une
suspension du contrat de travail ce qui
fait que ce sont des salariés qui
pendant le temps où ils bénéficient de
ces deux
assurances vieillesse particulière
relève du régime général donc c'est déjà
le cas en quelque sorte et donc nous on
ne suit pas ça c'est à dire que c'est le
régime général qui suit ces périodes
[Musique]
sur la pénibilité simplement pour
l'ensemble de l'assistance pour dire que
sur dans ce domaine on a un dispositif
de branches qui nous paraît tout à fait
performant et adapté à la pénibilité
réelle du travail avec d'une part sur 6
17 ans de service actifs au moins
possible débarrasser 57 ans et puis un
dispositif qui s'est ajouté depuis 2009
à la à l'initiative des employeurs et
syndicats de la branche qui est que nous
avons un compte
incompé par une retraite ou des jours
qui s'ajoutent pour la pénibilité et
donc ce dispositif tel que nous le
vivons dans la branche cernes bien le
problème de PIB pour notre branche vous
avez une pension minimum
on a une pension minimum et les pensions
minimum je vous ai donné les chiffres
détaillés je peux je peux vous donner là
on a valeur 2023 alors pour pour 15 ans
1040 valeurs 2023 1930 euros pour 15 ans
et puis 1047
pour 30 ans et 1000
163,55 € ce qui veut dire qu'en fait
nous sommes au-dessus si vous faites les
calculs nous sommes au-dessus de ce qui
est prévu dans les mini dans les minimum
qui est de droit commun de la retraite
progressive actuellement vous pouvez en
vous pouviez déjà l'appliquer non
n'était pas concernez-vous pensez que ça
va toucher nombre d'agents
alors ça peut
évidemment nous n'en bénéficions pas
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un plus de la
loi
mais enfin sur le sur l'effet je crois
pas qu'on est que c'est difficile à
mesurer c'est difficile à mesurer on
peut participer par contre ça sera un
plus pour le régime parce
qu'effectivement les salariés n'en
bénéficient pas actuellement absolument
c'est une avancée pour le régime tout à
fait absolument en cumul emploi retraite
vous en avez déjà beaucoup
parce que là ça vous a été ouvert
on le suit pas particulièrement mais
effectivement enfin quand on se dit
qu'il ne suit pas c'est que on fait des
contrôles au moment où les personnes
atteignent l'âge légal pour s'assurer
qu'il respecte les plafonds qui sont les
conditions qui sont remplies mais on n'a
pas un suivi annuel de du nombre de
personnes qui bénéficient du cumulent
leur retraite mais effectivement le
dispositif est ouvert aussi pour les
salariés des Ig actuellement pourquoi on
en a pas de suivi parce que ça n'est pas
utile pour notre gestion si vous voulez
on est sous vraiment sous contrainte de
coûts par contre on a toujours
une répercussion sur le régime pour
demain
dans le cadre du projet de loi notre
compréhension du sujet et que les
personnes qui actionneront le dispositif
cumulant par retraite cotiseront au
régime général pour la partie d'activité
qu'il reprendront donc à ce moment-là
c'est le régime général qui le suivent
donc nous notre difficulté sera
peut-être d'échanger des informations
avec la CNAV pour que on est bien la
connaissance des personnes mais à notre
connaissance on devrait pas avoir
d'impact financier ni en gestion
particulièrement ok les autres questions
portées sur les effectivement
l'équilibre du régime par rapport aux
nouveaux entrants mais ça on verra ça ce
sera en plfs
24 donc je vous les pose pas aujourd'hui
merci
bien Sylvie vermeyer pour compléter
merci madame la Présidente
j'aurais juste quelques questions un peu
plus précises vous avez donné le montant
de la pension minimale est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner le montant de la
pension moyenne
première question deuxième question
est-ce que les agents bénéficient de
prime de fin de carrière parce que vous
avez dit que le taux de remplacement
était assez voisin de celui de la
fonction publique mais est-ce qu'il y a
des primes de fin de carrière
troisièmement vous avez parlé de l'âge
de départ
anticipé 60,4 je crois que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure est-ce que à l'issue de
de cette arrêt il y a des agents qui
redeviennent contractuels qui voilà qui
contradictualise de nouveau
à votre connaissance qui reprennent une
activité derrière et
et finalement quel est le montant de la
contribution publique totale au travers
de la taxe spéciale
pour les derniers éléments que vous avez
60,3 voilà
je sais pas si on a le chiffre là moi je
deuxième question est-ce qu'il y a des
primes de fin de carrière
bonne nouvelle pour moi
excusez-moi excusez-moi
je rapproche je disais qu'effectivement
il y avait des indicatifs de primes de
fin de carrière qui était alloués
aux salariés qui quittaient le régime
pour le préciser on peut le préciser
dans le questionnaire et je peux pas
dire de bêtises donc
je vous le préciserai dans le
questionnaire je vais le rajouter et
pour ce qui concerne la contribution
publique totale au travers de la taxe
spéciale alors ce que vous expliquez
Nicolas tout à l'heure c'est que la
contribution tarifaire qui a été
instaurée en 2005 dans le cadre de la
réforme du financement c'est une
fraction de la
facture que les consommateurs payés qui
étaient versés aux entreprises donc
c'est quelque part un décalage
d'éléments de facturation qui a été
isolée aujourd'hui la collecte de la
contribution tarifaire représente
environ 1,7 milliards d'euros
mais sur ces 1,7 millions d'euros la
totalité ne vient pas financer la
retraite une partie vient financer les
prestations une autre partie vient
financer la soulte qui est reversée au
régime général qui s'approche des 400
millions d'euros quand on en parle sur
l'année 2023 une soulte qui était versée
sur 20 annuités donc la dernière unité
sera versée en 2024 et le dernier point
c'est les excédents de trésorerie que
vous indiquez Nicolas Michaël c'est
qu'on a des excédents et ces excédents
ne viennent pas je dirais enrichir ou
faire une sorte de cagnotte pour le
régime ce sont des excédents de
trésorerie qui quelque part restent sur
notre compte bancaire et simplement ce
qui a été évoqué Nicolas mijaville c'est
que cet argent est mis à disposition de
la cause de manière préférentielle
plutôt que laisser sur sur note sur les
comptes de chez notre partenaire
bancaire et donc profite quelque part au
régime général puisque ça permet de
réduire la
le recours au marché pour financer la
dette côté régime général
juste une dernière question le montant
de vous coûte gestion vous avez dit que
vous étiez assez performant donc quel
est le coût soit global de votre gestion
soit le coût unitaire
on pourra faire le calcul par rapport au
communitaire j'ai pas en tête mais on a
moins de 30 millions d'euros de de
coup de gestion de budget de
fonctionnement annuel
très bien alors nous avons des questions
Laurence Cohen Philippe mouillé et
Raymonde pensée mange et Cathy a pour ce
poly aussi
pour toutes ces explications moi je
voudrais revenir sur le ce que vous vous
avez dit qu'il me semble très important
c'est que le régime est équilibré et et
autonome et que voilà il y a une grande
satisfaction à juste titre d'ailleurs du
côté des pensionnés mais moi je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être au niveau de la
de notre commission des affaires
sociales peut-être un peu plus détaillé
vous vous êtes bien habitué à à ce
régime mais parce que on présente les
les régimes spéciaux dont le vôtre comme
étant des régimes privilégiés nous au
niveau de ma famille politique on
appelle ça des régimes pionniers et on
pourrait on pourrait plutôt y tendre que
essayer de tirer les droits vers le bas
et quand on parle d'ouverture des droits
à la retraite il y a quand même des
conditions qui sont extrêmement précises
dans votre régime et je pense
particulièrement et j'aimerais que vous
apportiez des des
précisions à mes collègues pourquoi je
dis ça c'est parce que j'ai été visité
un site dans le Val-de-Marne des gaziers
et qui m'ont expliqué leur régime et
c'est pas si facile que ça parce que
effectivement si l'âge moyen des départs
anticipés est de 58 ans c'est
essentiellement pour les services actifs
et ça concerne 20% 20% seulement des
agents et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire mes
chers collègues le service actif ça veut
dire la pénibilité et dans la pénibilité
c'est les ce sont les astreintes le
travail de nuit les charges qui sont
lourdes et j'ai appris quelque chose que
je ne connaissais pas mais peut-être
beaucoup d'entre vous le connaissent
c'est l'exposition au cm ce sont donc
toutes les substances cancérigènes etc
et donc c'est ça qui recouvre le fait
qu'ils puissent y avoir un départ et
anticiper et il y a eu une réforme qui
est quand même passée par là qui est la
réforme verte en 2010 et qui disent que
vous avez un peu dit mais je pense qu'il
faut aller plus en profondeur il faut
avoir travaillé au moins 17 ans dans
l'industrie électrique gaziaire pour
bénéficier d'un d'un départ anticipé
donc ça ne concerne que 20% donc je
voulais dire ça parce qu'il faut faire
un lien aussi avec l'attractivité des
métiers parce que quand hier je suis
avant-hier je suis allée sur le site et
bien les personnes que j'ai rencontrées
m'ont dit que vraiment elles étaient
fatiguées et s'il y avait un allongement
du départ à la retraite et bien il
remettraient en cause finalement et bien
de rester dans dans cette dans cette
entreprise donc est-ce que vous pouvez
donner des des éléments plus précis sur
ces différents les différents facteurs
que j'ai j'ai nommé je vous remercie les
mouillé on va prendre les quatre
questions merci pour votre intervention
alors peut-être en miroir de
l'intervention de coin je voudrais
revenir moi sur l'équilibre de de caisse
parce que certes il n'y a pas
d'attribution directe de l'État pour
l'équipe des textes mais quelque part
c'est une taxe sur la facture c'est la
taxe ou la facture qui vient financer la
caisse à travers cette contribution donc
notamment de transport donc ma question
si je voulais savoir c'est est-ce que
c'est le contribution est calculée au
regard des besoins de la caisse ou
est-ce que elle est figée quelle est la
progression de ces contributions qui est
prélevée sur les factures d'électricité
donc c'est un peu la question puisque
c'est un moyen indirect c'est de notre
façon de pouvoir financer la caisse
d'autonomes première question deuxième
question on a vu et vous l'avez très
bien dit que la remise en cause un
certain nombre de d'éléments concernant
la pénibilité est une difficulté parce
que on voit bien moi je pense on a parlé
du service sélectif mais les services
aussi insalubre par contre en parallèle
vous conservez le compte épargne jour
retraite dans le système nouveau proposé
et quelque part est-ce que c'est pas un
moyen de devenir compenser puisque vous
êtes à même à travers la profession de
pouvoir modifier les règles de
fonctionnement d'attribution de ce
compte épargne du jour est-ce que c'est
pas moyen finalement de venir compenser
ce qui est perdu d'un côté que vous
revendiquez comme étant une perte
importante mais est-ce que vous avez pas
la main finalement pour venir la
compenser sur un outil que vous
maîtrisez à vos mains complètement dans
de façon à venir atténuer l'effet de la
réforme donc ça c'était la deuxième
remarque et puis troisième sujet je je
ne peux qu'agaisser quand vous évoquez
le fait de l'attractivité du métier à
chaque fois quelque part on a une perte
de système d'organisation mais c'est
vrai pour vous c'est vrai pour beaucoup
de profession c'est un système général
voilà donc deux questions sur le calcul
de l'équilibre financier de la Caisse et
deuxième finalement est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas en main la capacité de venir
compenser les pertes d'attractivité du
métier par d'autres outils que vous
maîtrisez sur justement la pénibilité
vraiment de penserment j'ai 4/3 pour ce
polir vraiment oui merci alors moi je
vais te plus courte que j'avais pensé
parce que Laurence Cohen a dit beaucoup
de choses que j'aurais pu dire et moi il
y a deux choses qui restent pour moi une
question vraiment j'ai pas la réponse
vous avez parlé de la pénibilité qui est
un dispositif de branche et je pense que
dans l'avenir ces dispositifs de
branches contenus
de la comment dirais-je de la faible
prise en compte de la pénibilité dans la
loi générale va devoir s'amplifier si on
veut vraiment résoudre enfin résoudre
prendre en compte le problème de la
pénibilité donc vous avez dit
ce dispositif de branche permet donc de
partir à 57 ans et j'aimerais savoir bon
par rapport à la hiérarchie des sources
mais 57 ans est-ce que ça va le porter à
59 ans comment l'âge que vous avez dans
votre dispositif de branche avec la loi
générale désormais alors or je dirais
peut-être
les statutaires je sais pas il y a
peut-être là aussi de différence et bon
peut-être un peu revenir sur
ce dispositif de branche moi je veux
bien un petit peu
en poursuite de ce qu'a dit Laurence
mieux connaître les éléments de permis
de pénibilité et ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que vous prenez en compte
l'exposition au CMR et c'est drôle parce
que ça c'est le genre de de
contraintes de pénibilité que l'on dit
impossible pour pour les autres
employeurs à prendre en compte donc si
vous pouvez nous dire vous comment vous
prenez en compte cette exposition aussi
au CMR parce qu'effectivement
l'astreinte comme a dit Laurence le
travail de nuit les charges lourdes oui
qui ont été exclus et qui reviennent
quand même de façon très altérée mais
l'exposition
que vous ne disiez en quoi vous c'est
possible de les prendre en compte alors
que en règle générale les employeurs et
le patronat de façon générale dit que ça
c'est absolument impossible de d'en
faire un critère de un critère
objectifable merci patron et pour
terminer Katia pour ce poli oui notre
collègue a déjà dit beaucoup de choses
horoscane moi je j'ai deux questions à
vous poser monsieur parce que vous avez
bien relié effectivement que le régime
était équilibré et qu'il était même
excédentaire
qu'il était même excédentaire j'ai cru
entendre que ce régime était
excédentaire voilà donc moi j'ai une
question le régime spécial donc va
disparaître comme Laurence Lady nous
appelons ça pour notre part régime
pionnier parce que vous avez y compris
dans vos propos dit que ce métier
aujourd'hui était moins attractif que ce
métier était moins attractif que vous
aviez plus de difficultés donc s'il est
moins tractif c'est que vous avez plus
de difficultés dans les recrutements je
pense que cela est dû à forcément cette
casse du service public quand même que
peu à peu on a on a on a fait en sorte
que gouvernement après gouvernement et
bien il y a cette case du service public
alors moi j'ai alors je sais bien qu'il
y a 156 entreprises dans votre branche
etc alors j'aimerais savoir comment ça
va se passer parce que comment vont
faire les comment vont faire les
salariés lors des négociations annuelles
puisque vous avez vous allez avoir deux
régimes
ce dont qui dépend de du régime actuel
et demain vous l'avez dit ce qui
dépendront du régime donc général donc
comment vont se passer les négociations
les négociations annuelles moi j'ai un
peu de mal à voir comment cela peut se
passer et puis c'est c'est négociations
seront-ils finalement scindés en deux
groupes voilà c'est c'est la question
que j'aimerais vous poser je vous
remercie toutes les questions un seul
directeur d'abord merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
la qualité d'autres questions qui
correspondent à ce que je vous avais dit
en introduction j'avais insisté sur
l'attractivité du secteur je vois que
c'est une question qui vous intéresse à
juste titre et je vois aussi que dans
vos questions il y a finalement on
n'abandonne quelque chose on met
quelques qu'est-ce que l'on mettrait à
la place pour pour continuer à ce que le
secteur soit attractif pour que ça
continue ça reste à faire de lance de
notre économie pour que nous soyons
chauffés comme je l'ai dit sous forme
facétie en introduction alors premier
point sur la sur la pénibilité ce que
vous m'invitiez à faire madame sénatrice
c'est madame le sénateur c'est de c'est
pardon
Google est en retard sur sur et en
retard sur vous mesdames
j'adopterai j'adopterai vos
votre vue donc ce qui est
ce qui est important je crois j'ai déjà
un petit peu expliqué cela et désolé si
je mets pas assez de chair autour du
propos
la nous avons un dispositif de
pénibilité qui aujourd'hui nous paraît
adapté dans la branche effectivement
c'est 17 ans de service actifs vous
l'avez à vous avez incité sur le fait
que c'était long tout à l'heure pour
pouvoir partir à 57 ans et ça ajoute je
les dis également le dispositif qui a
été mis en place ce dispositif de
branche également
les comptes épargne retraite
qui joue qui sont qui ont été mises en
place en 2009 à l'initiative de la
branche donc tout cela nous le trouvons
je crois que au vu des des partenaires
de la Manche c'est pour l'instant
quelque chose qui semble adapté aux
conditions de pénibilité du travail dans
notre domaine je saurais pas vous
répondre à la question sur le sur les
CMR on va vérifier le point et elle sera
dans le dans les compléments aux
réponses au questionnaires on vous
donnera la réponse précise sur ce sujet
comment se fait-il que nous ayons ce
traitement dans notre branche je reviens
maintenant sur le système de financement
donc désolé madame la sénatrice je peux
pas aller beaucoup plus en un mais je
crois que vous avez raison d'insister
sur le je l'ai fait moi-même dans mon
introduction sur attention cette
pose indirectement le question de
l'actrice l'attractivité dessus ce
secteur qui a été soulevé dans d'autres
enceintes et vous le savez
dans et dans la durée puisque c'est
vraiment une industrie qui est là pour
rester je l'espère dans notre pays donc
et nous notons depuis un certain nombre
d'années qu'on est moins attractif alors
peut-être parce qu'il y a des
inquiétudes sur le devenir du secteur
mais peut-être aussi simplement parce
que la vision réductrice de dire la
retraite est un avantage qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas tel que ce que ce veulent
bien croire le citoyen éventuellement
mal informé mais la retraite ce n'est
qu'un élément d'un paquet social et
salarial et d'un élément dans lequel il
y a la pénibilité il y a tout un tas
tout un tas d'autres dispositifs et je
pense que l'intelligence
de l'État actionnaire puisqu'il est
question d'une renationalisation du plus
gros acteur de la branche d'EDF des
employeurs de la branche des syndicats
de la branche de devra porter vraiment
accorder tout ça en attention à comment
fait en sorte que nous soyons un bon
niveau pour rester si non pionnier en
tout cas à bon niveau au niveau
d'exigence que requiert cette branche le
point que vous évoquiez sur le
financement sur la CTA alors moi je me
permets de Monsieur le Sénateur de
répéter que la CTA de mon point de vue
et de notre point de vue est totalement
neutre c'est-à-dire que on a vraiment
fait un c'est une écriture d'une
certaine manière c'était déjà dans le
prix il faut bien que quelqu'un couvre
cette charge et vous avez vu que nous
avons des taux de cotisation employeur
qui sont plus élevés que dans le dans le
régime général nous avons vu que nous
avons des côtés taux de cotisation
employeur qui sont sensiblement plus
élevés que dans le régime général donc
tous ces équilibres passent par là et la
CTA je le répète n'est qu'un pur
transfert d'un élément pris chiffre
d'affaires est pris faire un élément de
taxe et taxe propre à notre secteur
et pour couvrir de manière dédiée le
passé le passé passé à 2004 du régulier
oui même la mécanique elle est elle est
aux mains de
plusieurs acteurs le montant de la
contribution tarifaire qu'on collecte
c'est une taxe qui est déterminée par
les powerpres publiques qui assiste sur
des éléments tarifaires la cheminement
qui est assez d'acheminant qui est fixé
par la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie
et la loi prévoit à l'origine que cette
taxe soit déterminée pour financer les
charges à financer par la caisse par le
régime sur une période de 5 ans ensuite
il y a des aléas qui font que on
respecte pas toujours c'est c'est 5 ans
mais globalement la mécanique générale
et la suivante aujourd'hui
on a eu une évolution tarifaire en 2021
sur le tag d'acheminion d'électricité
qui a conduit compte tenu d'un certain
nombre d'incertitudes sur les sur les
hypothèses les pouvoirs publics à
retenir le maintien d'un taux
c'est-à-dire une neutralisation du
montant de CTA collecté qui est de
l'ordre de 1 milliard 7
sans que l'augmentation de l'assiette
c'est très technique l'augmentation de
l'assiette TURPE qui est l'assiette
d'acheminement électricité viennent
augmenter
inconsidérablement les collectes de CETA
donc il y a un contrôle il y a un
contrôle qui est là dessus qui est fait
il y a pas de il y a pas de de doutes là
dessus et tous les ans lorsque moi je
présente la réalité des comptes de la
caisse on fait le point notamment avec
les tutelles pour leur signaler quelles
sont les situations exactement des
excédents et qu'elles sont aussi les
perspectives que nous avons parce que il
faut bien retenir que la contribution
tarifaire comme je le disais elle
finance les droits spécifiques passés
réguliers c'est-à-dire une fraction des
charges acquises avant le 31 avant le
1er janvier 2005 et une fraction de la
soulte qui est reversé à la CNAV cette
soulte c'est 400 millions d'euros ça va
s'arrêter en 2025 donc de fait ça sera
un surcroît de différentiel entre les
produits collectés d'un anniversaire 7
donc 500 millions d'euros de moins à
financer donc vous voyez bien que
l'excédent il va augmenter de temps et
la deuxième chose c'est que les charges
à financer au titre des droits acquis
passer réguler d'avant 2005 ils sont en
diminution puisque on a passé le cap qui
était aux alentours des années 2018-2019
et la démographiquement aujourd'hui on
est dans une phase de de descente de
décrue et naturellement effectivement la
CTA est en train de partir en extinction
maintenant je rappelle toujours aussi
que la CTA elle a été créée donc c'est
un élément du tarif qui a été isolé mais
qui légalement est une imposition de
toute nature c'est un élément une
ressource d'État tel qu'elle a été
retenue par par l'Union européenne
lorsqu'elle a donné son accord sur ce
dispositif
ressource d'État donc ça nous appartient
pas non plus ça n'appartient pas au
régime d'accord
et monsieur le sénateur vous faisiez le
geste de la pente effectivement c'est
gestes là on peut les faire mais à
d'autres moments on les fait dans
l'autre sens moi quand j'ai pris mon
mandat il y a 6 ans mon prédécesseur m'a
expliqué que j'allais manger que manger
mais fonds propres moi manger mes fonds
propres car je n'aurai plus de CDA
c'était à d'après les prévisions de la
déjà c'est très dépendant des prévisions
d'échec dont on conçoit que c'est très
complexe à faire les prévisions sur le
turpicieux sur la paracheminement et
comme vient de vous l'expliquer monsieur
Duchêne à l'instant de toutes les façons
il y a une certaine neutralité puisque
ça ne reste pas dans le régime
c'est l'État qui fixe le Turc donc de
façon il peut directement être jugé par
[Musique]
oui je voudrais préciser ma question
parce que oui peut-être vous l'avez pas
vous avez dit 17 ans de service d'abord
effectivement la durée des services va
pas changer par cette loi ça a été
dit est-ce que vous pouvez me confirmer
d'ailleurs que la fois d'avance est
passé de 15 à 17 je crois mais ce que je
voulais savoir c'est de 57 ans lui le 57
ans est-ce qu'il va bouger par la loi
on peut pas vous répondre formellement
parce que ce ne sommes pas nous qui
tenons le crayon sur le sujet mais dans
notre compréhension du projet de loi
effectivement on passerait de 57 à 59
ans mais c'est pas nous qui qui ont
décidé voilà nous notre rôle ça sera de
mettre en œuvre ce que le pouvoir
réglementaire aura fixé peut-être
peut-être préciser que ceux qui
disposent de cette départ d'agent
anticipé de 57 partent en moyenne à quel
âge
parce qu'on a vu pour la Hyères avec
Raymonde était là on l'a vu par exemple
avec la CNRACL ceux qui sont à 57 qui
vont passer à 59 ans
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il part déjà
plus de 60 ans en moyenne le 57 c'est
l'âge minimum mais en fait pour avoir
les trimestres déjà aujourd'hui ils
partent déjà plus tard donc l'impact de
passer de 57 à 59 n'est pas un impact de
deux ans forcément sur la cnrsl c'est
pour ça qu'il faut nous préciser ça mais
on a vu que c'est un impact de neuf mois
supplémentaires il y a forcément un
impact mais comme tu dis c'est une
moyenne et la partie de la moyenne qui
était en dessous
[Musique]
en fait il y en a peu qui alors quelle
est la l'âge moyen de départ pour ceux
qui relèvent de la Oda
on vous donnera l'information par en
complément aux questions que vous nous
avez posées puisque j'ai pas la réponse
de chic mais on peut présumer quand même
ce que plus que dit Monsieur monsieur
Savary est exact puisque on a vu les
chiffres globaux tout à l'heure on a vu
que on était à 60,3 pour le total et il
était à 62,9 pour les départs non
anticipés donc quelque part c'est une
façon de répondre à votre question mais
la réponse beaucoup plus précise vous
sera donné dans le dans le complément au
questionnaire
et sur le CMR je l'ai déjà dit Madame on
vous donnera là aussi à une je l'ai pas
j'ai pas la réponse
15 et 17 oui
c'est bien cela madame
alors j'ai deux collègues se sont
rajoutés Annick Jacquemin et Monique
Lubin oui merci présidente
sauf à ce que je n'ai pas été attentif
Philippe mouillé vous avez interrogé sur
l'attractivité du métier comment la
compenser et j'ai été un petit peu
surprise par mais peut-être que j'ai mal
compris vos propos quand vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que une une grande
facette de l'attractivité du métier
c'est justement le départ en retraite
alors je trouve un peu dommage
un peu dommage des parents anticipé
voilà alors je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage pour des jeunes qui rentrent en
activité professionnelle d'avoir
cet objectif-là
pour toute leur carrière professionnelle
donc est-ce que vous pouvez détailler un
petit peu qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
développer pour justement rendre vos
métiers plus attractifs
en dehors du départ anticipé en retraite
je crois pas avoir 10 là tout à l'heure
j'ai peut-être mal compris mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas du tout évoqué que le départ
anticipé soit un élément d'attractivité
du secteur c'est en tout cas pas du tout
ma vision des choses et je crois pas je
crois pas l'avoir dit par contre qu'il y
ait des mesures
permettant des débats dans les
conditions pénibilités ou autre
parfaitement justifié ça c'est un
élément de respectivité du secteur après
les départs vous avez vu d'ailleurs que
dans la réponse à la question qui avait
été qui nous avait été envoyé sur les
départs anticipés pour une série de
raisons handicap etc ça représentait des
pourcentages qui sont somme toute très
modestes de l'ensemble des départs
anticipés donc
loin de moi de dire que ceux qui
prennent un départ anticipé parce qu'ils
ont envie de prendre un décaps des
parents anticipés c'est ça c'est
vraiment un élément fort d'attractivité
genre je dis pas non plus que c'est pas
un effort d'activité vous pouvez faire
un plan de carrière en vous disant dans
cette entreprise j'aurai la possibilité
de partir un peu plus tôt si je le
souhaite avec avec moins de revenus mais
c'est pas ce que je mettrai et je pense
pas que c'est ce que mettrai les
employeurs de la branche comme élément
d'attractivité l'élément d'activité sont
des éléments de bonne couverture sociale
des éléments salariés et puis des
éléments de conditions de travail qui
font qu'on est fier et et
sûr de travailler dans un secteur
c'est cela que je mettrai en avant
pour terminer merci madame la Présidente
moi je m'interroge sur finalement le
bien fondé de la de la mise à mort de ce
régime là puisqu'il est excédentaire
donc je vois pas très bien puisqu'on
nous présente ces régimes spéciaux et
notamment celui-là comme coutant cher au
contribuables ainsi de suite et donc je
vois pas très bien l'intérêt d'autant
plus que finalement
on va verser au régime général des
nouveaux salariés et donc à l'avenir des
nouvelles dépenses or j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il fallait équilibrer
nos régimes de retraite alors là on va
verser
certes quelques recettes mais mais
beaucoup de dépenses à l'avenir et la
deuxième chose c'est j'aimerais savoir
mais je suis pas sûr je ne suis pas
certaine que ça je suis certaine et même
que ça cette question ne peut pas
s'adresser à vous le fameux CTA
est-ce que est-ce que ou là ce fameux
c'était à est-ce que elle va être
restituée aux consommateurs
d'électricité
quand il y en aura plus besoin pour
financer les régimes spéciaux
je réponds
aux questions
c'est la dernière alors
je vais pas revenir longuement sur ce
sur ce que j'ai dit j'ai eu ce n'était
pas par malice mais c'est par
connaissance du secteur j'ai simplement
pointé le sujet d'attractivité parce que
on sait qu'elle est la situation
économique de secteur et que la question
d'actualité se pose et surtout parce que
étant dans la dernière partie de ma
carrière devenue un spécialiste de la
retraite j'ai été très très surpris de
voir tous les débats qui mettent
toujours le doigt sur la retraite alors
que ce n'est qu'un des éléments et ce
qu'il faut c'est raisonner pour une
branche d'activité est-ce que on couvre
bien par rapport aux besoins de la
nation est-ce qu'on couvre bien les
besoins de cette branche et donc c'est
simplement ce que j'ai voulu dire et je
vois que vous vous
avez vous allez dans ce dans ce sens
après je vais me positionne pas par
rapport à ce projet à ce projet de loi
ils sont en application sur le statut
c'est pas moi de me c'est pas moi de
dire c'est au législateur c'est le
gouvernement sur le l'autre point qui
était sur la
le deuxième point c'était sur la pardon
ah oui la restitution des excédents
alors là aussi c'est un choix qui est
vraiment me dépasse totalement je
comprends je comprends la logique de la
question qui est de dire s'il y a plus à
couvrir des charges passées il faut que
le trade le tarif se réduise je crois je
crois que l'économie n'est tarifs
électriques et gaziers est un sujet très
complexe aujourd'hui et donc je crois
que c'était c'est vraiment à ceux qui
ont charge
de décider là-dessus
très bien ben écoutez merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Directeur
un grand merci de votre attention et
[Musique]
on est temps très heureux d'avoir pu gel
l'espère on a mieux compris qu'elle
était régime parce que dans la
complexité des régimes des retraites il
est important qu'on puisse bien sûr que
nous avons pas su répondre dans le
questionnaire qui nous a été merci
beaucoup